okay
so that should hopefully
be up and running and people can see me
i can just get that out of my way
um did i accidentally tilt the thing no
it's fine hey folks
hope everyone's doing all right
uh hello carowind
ms wicked wolf baileys hello gozer
oh people can see me can you oh i mute
can people hear me oh dear
hold on
okay i people are definitely seeing me
can you hear me okay
is the question mute
crap one second um
see if we can get this sorted
oh now people can all right
so some people are saying they can't
hear me so people who are who are saying
i'm mute try refreshing the stream see
if that helps
okay hey everybody
i hope you're doing all right i am
missing something first of all
there we go that's better i am uh
i i i'm a little worn down if i'm going
to be completely honest
ms wicked wolf i introduced three of my
friends to you and now they're following
you on tick tock
them and dang near 90 000 other people
which is
scary found out yesterday
i'm uh gonna be playing
oren scaravello in little shop of
horrors in june
oh well that'll be fun
i hope that goes really well for you
i'm gonna introduce something uh
new new to this stream but most of you
are probably familiar with it because
i'm stealing this
idea from uh jesse gender which is
uh when i get um
when i get super chats um
people will get a heart for that i
thought about trying to do something
different like possibly blowing a kiss
but like i don't want to
uh have it be unsolicited uh
expressions of physical affection if
that's not your jam and so i said screw
it i'm stealing the concept from her
anyway i'll just steal the heart thing
so
shh don't tell jesse um
because it used to be just you know the
super chat men guaranteed i would read
your comment but i
i keep up with the chats pretty well
most of the time
anyway that it actually didn't seem like
that much of an
uh acknowledgement so
you know i thought a little something
extra
uh would it helped if i offered you a
virtual foot rub i'm not sure how much a
virtual one would help
i appreciate the thought though now um
here's here's the real question
about the stream is will i be able to
end this one without accidentally
starting a new stream where i film just
the chair
this time that's the real question
uh did you find me on tick tock yet i
did yes i cannot remember your username
now off the top my head so you'll have
to
forgive me that oregon had a snowstorm
last week
and i was homebound for five days we
actually lost power for almost 24 hours
but it's nothing compared to texas yeah
tex
texas like
obviously i have an awful lot of
um sympathy
for any people caught there but
at the state level in terms of the way
the state had set itself up they
they did this to themselves that's not
to say that anyone deserves to suffer
but like yeah honestly you don't think
people would mind the kiss
i'll tell you what if you want a kid if
you send me a super chat you can say
whether you want a kiss or a heart the
heart's the default the kiss is optional
how about we do that
no tongue that's extra
thank you jacob i appreciate that
favorite kind of donut
i actually oh i eat donuts so rarely at
this point
i used to really go for boston cream
those are nice
um but like i've been in vermont so long
that
really the only donuts i have anymore
are cider donuts which if you've never
had those
oh they're so good speaking of cider
grab this
that's still hot okay give that a minute
good thing that the chair stream is
literally just your chair and not you
doing something naughty well i mean like
i
i wouldn't really do anything that
naughty in the same chair i film in
at least as far as any of you know
it was on valentine's day just ate two
boxes of chocolates uh
ordered olive garden and watched disney
plus
like i that's basically the same thing i
did except i happened to be with liz but
like we i think we did take out and
watched a movie which is what we
normally do
anyways so
uh can you fake an irish accent
uh not a good one and like i
i'm really hesitant to even try like as
a joke
because i really i i'm much more
self-conscious
about um the idea
that i would be offending
someone with how bad i would be at it it
just it doesn't seem
as as fun as it did like when i used to
have more fun doing accents when i was
like in my 20s not that i really did
those on
on the channel or anything but just in
general did you see the new disney plus
update oh my god it's awesome
now i don't know if anything was
significantly updated in the us
i know the disney star thing where like
some of the more adult stuff
that went live everywhere else but the
thing is most of the
content that went on that is on hulu in
the u.s
and it was not added to disney plus and
i don't have hulu
so if there was something that happened
to disney plus in the us
i'm not aware of it but to my
understanding that was not something
that
i get to enjoy unless i had something on
my computer that said i was in another
country haven't tried that yet
not sponsored by the way
oh here's a random thought imagine the
doctors as drag queens well six
basically
is a drag queen have you seen that
outfit my god
i've been really into pro shots lately
professionally filmed
stage productions and i'm wondering have
you seen steven sondheim's musical
sunday in the park with george i haven't
even heard of that one actually
not familiar do you twerk
um i uh no
[Laughter]
twerking is not part of my my repertoire
i okay well i'll say okay so
there's there's two things about well
there's three things about twerking the
first is it's
there's a little bit and the it is cider
for the record this is warm cider
nothing added to it i swear
but there's three things about twerking
the first is is that there is
actually legitimately a little bit of
controversy within some performance and
dance circles as to whether or not is
appropriative for
white people to do it now i say
controversy because that's not
like a settled debate but it's up in the
air enough that i'm a little bit
uncomfortable participating for that
reason because
the practice has its roots in african
dance uh and in black culture uh
very firmly so that's i like that can
feel a little weird for me
beyond that i lack the booty for it to
really have it
pop well like i can do some of the moves
but like it doesn't it's not the same
impact i don't have enough of a butt
i have a bud i don't like have a flat
ass but i don't have that much of a butt
but then there's the third thing which
is
okay
how do i say this without getting the
stream demonetized
unless i'm tucked or wearing some kind
of undergarment that is
going to very firmly hold certain bits
in place
those flop around a lot when i try and
twerk and that's not comfortable
so there you go
how do you decide on what to eat uh
for the rest of your nights that's just
whatever
whether she's here or i'm there it's
just whatever we have the stuff for
she usually does small shopping trips so
we'll usually talk
um a few days before i come over about
what it is that that we'd like to have
while i'm there and we'll
she'll get the stuff in advance and we
kind of do the same thing here
like i'll we'll figure out if she wants
uh if we want to do
takeout or you know we both have our uh
have our cooking repertoires uh of stuff
have you ever read jojo's bizarre
adventure i know nothing about it except
seeing
other people review it online and that's
even that's only the anime
so um i don't know anyone who's read the
manga actually
one of my friends said that you kind of
look like you work
out because you look a bit muscular um
i wish i could claim that like i've
still got hang on
i've still got you know
some muscle mass but that's
that's my natural build and like i know
it looks like i'm i'm bragging now but
like i'm not trying to that's that's
just that's just what i've got that's
just what i'm working with um
sort of naturally i've like even when i
have
tried to get in the habit of working out
it's been stuff like riding
um an exercise bike or jogging it's
mostly lower leg
you know lower body and leg work i don't
work my arms i've never worked my arms
deliberately
if six was a drag queen he would go by
sexton
silly question does your kid cook or
know how she doesn't cook
she bakes sometimes um
but or she helps bake anyways but no she
isn't really into cooking uh all that
much
uh you and liz are very cute together
thank you pirates have you seen lindsey
ellis's
uh latest video i've um
i've started it um i haven't finished it
yet
i'm
i've sort of i've had a day of kind of
heavy media i spent the the bulk of my
day today watching
it's a sin i actually have to shoot that
review
after the live streams over so um you
know i i might give it a day or two
before i get to
uh to lindsay's can i see your shirt
yeah sure hang on a second
queer to the bone this is
uh bring that back
so this is another design by um
by hi-ho silver who i plugged i think
the last
saturday's video i plugged their stuff
so if you go to
hijosilverworks.com
it uh they have fantastic designs latest
ones that they came out with
it's this design of um of a moon sort of
behind
the clouds and it says unfazed
do you like bo burnham i do i haven't
checked out his latest stuff all that
much but i do i do like him and he's
very
um he is very self-aware and very
self-reflective a lot more than you
would think based off the pitch
of musical comedian
uh ever notice that the characters in
your first few videos look like they
should be working for channel awesome
well like i remember back in the day
when i used to wear the hat
um a lot which is actually just off
screen over there
like more than a few people said that i
look like doug walker although
the thing now is and this i i get this
on tick tock
nobody or at least no one has said it on
youtube that i've noticed but people
keep saying that i sat and i don't look
like but i
sound like hank green which
i don't i'm a lousy judge of
because you know we sound different in
our own heads so i'm not
a good judge of whether or not i sound
like him in the first place i don't
think i do
but i also have to come to the fact that
maybe
i don't know but i'm getting that a lot
it's weird
uh don't overload yourself with hard
watches get straining yeah i know
i know uh how many episodes of it's a
sin have you seen i finished it
i've watched all five so um
yeah are you a fan of steam-powered
giraffe
i know that name i don't remember why i
know that name
it's a band isn't it
i don't like i i don't i don't know
um who's your
least favorite queen from six um
whatever um god they're
trying to remember their actual names
give me a second because
it's catherine of aragorn she's cool and
then
it's amberlynn she's cool and then i
i cannot remember it's a
it's a toss-up for me between number
three and number six
because they're both kind of boring at
least compared to the other ones
uh closing my eyes and picturing hank i
can kind of hear it
yeah i mean like i think part of it
might be when i do tick tocks i
i'm usually deliberately talking a lot
faster because i
am trying to cram whatever it is i'm
trying to say into the limited amount of
time i have to do a tick tock
and i don't know if that sets it off a
little bit more
to people's ear
there are worse people to sound like
than hank green i mean like hank green
seems like a decent sword all things
considered
it's a sin broke me um episode three was
the one where i cried um
on that one not to say that was the um
the only sad part of that
show it wasn't but that was the that was
the episode that got
me so stuff with colin and
um his mother that was
uh
jane seymour and catherine park yes
thank you jane seymour is the most
boring i think
is the stephen punk band the lead
vocalist as a trans woman
that's why i've heard them before
um but uh yeah no i don't
i think i might have sought out a
couple of their um
a couple of their songs but i don't i
don't remember now
uh that lindsay l this villa video was
very eye-opening i didn't even
remember the transphobia in some of
those movies yeah it's
uh it's in a lot of places
are you watching season three of
american gods nope i don't have stars it
looked like crap season two was crap
screw it i mean and keep in mind i only
reviewed the first two seasons because
uh because somebody paid me um
i mean granted the uh the first season
was phenomenal sorry
there's i've got kind of a kind of a
ring on my
computer now where i'd set the mug down
i shouldn't be putting it there
okay did its ascendant make you cry yeah
episode three did
can you crow like peter pan i mean about
as well as he
the thing is i've never seen a pan do a
convincing
crow they're always kind of like yeah
that sounds like a person
doing a crow so like i i don't know i
just felt like it was supposed to sound
like a legitimate
crow and it never does if gina chrono
wasn't working with ben shapiro i'd
probably be more sympathetic to her
i mean i'm not um
i'm not shocked by that development
that that is um
trying to think of how i want to say
this
um and yes it is two cider
i got a cinnamon stick in it and
and everything um so
here's the thing about
carano now you know throwing her lot in
with ben shapiro
it is certainly distinctly
possible that it's something she would
have been inclined to do anyway
but only wouldn't have done because it
would have been bad for her career
and let's not kid ourselves no matter
what you think of benji perry even if
you like him
going in leaving lucasfilm for a deal
with him that's not a good career move
so maybe it's something she would have
been inclined to do
but it just would have been a bad career
decision anyway
but if that's not the case
there is a tendency for people
um like this
to when called out
and especially if there are consequences
um and sometimes even if not even if the
consequence is
people are yelling at them on twitter
which
try being trans on twitter for a hot day
a hot minute and
see how well they can stand up to that
but
um the thing is
that when they feel they
are being attacked by let's just go with
the left
the natural inclination for a lot of
them is to dig in their heels
and double down because
to apologize is
to admit a fault that they're not
prepared to admit because they don't
think they did anything wrong
so the natural thing for a lot of people
to do is to instead
flee to
whoever is going to think that they're
right in the views that they've
expressed
it's why i have no doubt
that when jk rowling started getting
initial pushback
on um following transphobic
um people on twitter and when she got
pushed back on maya four stater i don't
doubt
that when she got pushed back on that
that she retreated
to whatever spaces were feeding her the
turf ideology because they
she knew that they would validate her
it i don't i don't want to put too much
emphasis on this analogy
but it's basically retreating to
enablers it's like
getting called out for drinking too much
and by some of your friends and then
saying to them well screw you and then
store me off to go and hang out with
your friends
who drink just as much as you do
um it's kind of that same very human
um reaction and i say very human because
i don't want to
[Music]
demonize that thought process because i
think it's something that a lot of us
are inclined towards it's just
unfortunately in the case of someone
like
jk rowling or gina carano it inclines
them
toward just diving deeper into
some very very troubling
and sometimes even openly hateful
modes of thought and no that's not me
calling gina chrono a hate criminal i'm
talking broadly so
you know not that uh it's it's funny i
still
i still will always qualify my
statements
and i still be very careful with my
words even though i'm pretty sure that
nobody who actually wants to start a
fight with me is in the chat
and if they are they've probably been
banned because i have awesome mods
uh who jump on that nonsense when they
start trolling me
um but i my natural inclination
is always to qualify these statements
and
be as specific as i can
and to always explain that if i'm making
a broad statement that that is what i'm
doing
just it's just a habit i've developed at
this point
and i don't know how much of it is
excuse me um me trying to cover my own
butt
and just making sure i'm not getting
taken out of context which of course
some people will anyway or just
um me trying to preemptively
uh head things off
i can't i can't watch grand lineman
shows anymore such a vile human being
yeah i heard about his latest
nonsense oh my god
like okay
i think as much as
at this point jk rowling is
almost more well known within
um the general consciousness for her
transphobic beliefs as she
is for writing harry potter graham
linnaman
he uh or litaham or what however you
pronounce it
he when was the last time he did
anything other than be publicly
transphobic
because he seems to have decided that
that is his life
now and i strongly suspect
that if jk rowling didn't still have
whatever
um creative drive
pushes her to be a writer that she might
have
well she might still end up in that same
flipping place which is just
embarrassing
have you oh have i finished shit's creek
yet no i'm i'm going through that one
slowly i'm in season two um
on that one i really should um
i really should finish the second season
of avatar
because i've been sitting on the last
episode for a while
um because
spoiler alert i'm not as hooked into it
as everybody has been telling me i would
be
i'm really sorry
but you know i'll um i'll set myself
up on a um on a target range for that at
a later date
so everyone can get really angry with me
because i'm sure they will mod squad yes
yes all the love to the mods seriously
uh
yeah but the issue with rolling is that
now that it's
affected her she's going to channel into
her writing
uh a la the transphobically written
serial killer in her detective series
you know okay here's what's really
and like in this this sounds
petty but i i'm gonna dig at this
anyways
oh hold on um you can find a video on
here bbc
singing competition for the actor who
plays calling performing you'll be back
oh
lovely so like here's here's the thing
about
her invoking that trope
in that in that detective novel
the fact that that's even in there
to me means one of two things
i have not read any of her thriller
work so i can't make this call
but given how tired
that trope is how it has been run into
the ground
since the flippin seventies
the idea of a serial killer dressing as
a woman to either evade
police or because as part of his
motivation as a killer
or to invade women's spaces or whatever
having it as a component of the killer
is
so old and so worn out
the fact that she put it in that novel
means she either knows
nothing about the cliches of the genre
she's writing in
in which case she she decided to leap
from children's fantasy to adult thrills
and just thought
i know what i'm doing and didn't bother
to look into the genre she's working in
or or if she does know the genre
then there's no possible way she doesn't
know that's a cliche
and she decided that making that point
making that an element of her story was
more important
than avoiding a dumb trite
harmful tired boring
cliche of the genre
so she is either
really bad at her job as a writer
because you need to know what is
standard in the genre you're working in
so that you don't just write a generic
piece of garbage
or she cares more about pushing this
thought train down whatever
broken track it's headed on then she
does about actually telling a good story
take your pick
ah sorry i just got here you're talking
about jk rowling and yeah
there were some questions that set me
off we can move off that topic
muppet show on disney plus uh is on
disney plus now when i first heard that
i squealed
squeal-worthy although i do find the um
the warning they put ahead of it made me
tilt my head slightly the only thing
that i can think
of because it's basically like a this
represents old modes of thinking that
were wrong and it's culturally
insensitive whatever the only thing that
i can think of that they're trying to
account for is the sweetest chef
either that or there's stuff in the
muppet show that i don't remember
which is possible i suppose back when i
was watching the muppet show i
was getting stoned a lot but you know
whatever
uh after seeing a few short horror
movies by
karen gillan i feel after some time she
would make a good guest writer for a
future series of doctor who
what are your thoughts i didn't know
that she was writing
um so i i'm
fascinated um but i
don't have an opinion i have to go have
a good night okay
all right leprechaun master thank you
for stopping in i really appreciate it
uh family guy is on disney plus now
now is that in the u.s i think that's it
i think that's everywhere else pretty
sure family guy's on hulu
over here um have you been recommended
kinder or snake dance um i
they they're on the eventual to-do list
um now down the ranking a bit because i
just did a fifth starker
stalker
just did a fifth doctor's story over in
the break room so i probably won't do
another one for a little bit although i
suppose the um
uh the upside of um
having done resurrection of the dogs is
i feel like i'm finally nailing down
what i don't like about davidson's era
i might finally be getting there i'm
fine i'm figuring out bits and pieces as
time goes on as to why i don't like him
um do you wear green on st patrick's day
um
if i if i remember which is rarely
noelle clark who plays mickey smith
wrote a torchwood episode i didn't know
that he was directing for a little bit
too
family guys on international markets
yeah that's what i thought yeah this
came up earlier because disney added its
whole
like disney star thing but that's not in
the u.s
all that content's on hulu here which is
a completely separate service
requiring a separate flippin
subscription
whereas everybody else rest of the world
just gets it as part of disney plus now
great
ah if they cast you on a broadway
production of glee would you do it
well i'm assuming well
um they'd have to pay me
and they'd have to sponsor me into
actors equity
to get me onto broadway so for that
alone yes
if i had if i had a career and a choice
of roles
would i do that no if i was me as i am
currently living
nobody would know uh with no uh
professional union credentials of any
kind
yeah sure i'd do that the original
muppet show was produced by atv
a british television company i did know
that um
i did uh
is it weird that eleven is my favorite
doctor despite the fact that he is my
least favorite era of new who
i don't think so um i don't think that's
any more different than
um 12 being my favorite doctor but uh
and
me having a much lower opinion of david
tennant's
tenth doctor than most people and yet
series four which is a david tennant
series is my favorite series
of the show so yeah no i get it
have you listened to any big finish
that's uh free on spotify
uh they have the first 50 main range and
some fourth doctor stuff i haven't yet
because
i don't have time i'm i'm i'm really
trying to focus on
excuse me on trying to catch up
on um
on commissioned reviews which i'm
backlogged on so that's a big part of my
focus right now that and you know
keeping up with things like
one division and all the stuff that i
normally do on a regular basis the
saturday
videos the take two reviews and then the
firescape stuff for the podcast so like
i've got a pretty full plate
uh as it is do you have irish ancestry
not to any significant degree probably
like tiny amounts
here and there because i'm primarily
english
um and you know the the aisles get a
little the british isles get a little
mixed in there but
i'm ver i'm very heavily english
like um
family came over on the on the mayflower
english um i've got a little bit of
scottish
um mcnabb family but again that's
that's a minority it is vast majority
uh english for for my lineage
not to be that guy go ahead be that guy
but davison actually has a really good
and somewhat subtle arc if you watch
an order get the full story of his era
that may be true and it may be possible
that i'm doing a disservice by jumping
around but
you know that's how i'm approaching it
and that's what i'm going to do
thank you real life julie have a heart
uh hey nathaniel what's your absolute
favorite girl scout cookie
because you see it's cookie time again
it is indeed uh samoas
the the caramel coconut ones oh
oh my god they are so flippin dangerous
those things because because they're one
of those ones that like the the
the suggested serving size is two
cookies
like yeah right
thin mints are good too i do like those
as well
the song sexy and i know it is oh
i missed it something about the song
sexy and i know it ah
sexy i know it perfectly defines you i'm
not a big fan of that song i don't like
the beat
taikawa tt is directing a star wars
movie what are your thoughts i won't
have thoughts until i know what it's
actually going to be about
can you fake a scottish accent well like
i said with the irish
yes but not well and i don't want to
offend anybody
love your videos currently uh
re-watching xeno i was wondering what
you think of it
who's your favorite character i've only
ever seen a couple of episodes of xena
here and there
it's one of those things that i'm
reluctant to go back to because
since i don't have specific nostalgia
for it
i'm really kind of worried that i'm just
not going to be able to enjoy it in
the spirit that it was intended do you
knowingly have any english
relatives who still live in the uk no
because they all left on the
flippin mayflower
i mean y i probably but it'll be like
cousins so far back on the friggin tree
that it might as well be in a different
orchard
ah
did a dna test and i found out i'm 100
that [ __ ] oh no sorry um i found out
i'm i'm sorry pirates i couldn't resist
i'm almost half english a quarter irish
like i don't know um what the actual
percentage
is for me but it is uh it is severely
uh severely english because because i've
got
i've got heavy english on both sides of
my family
um lady gaga oreos are delicious
i'll take your word for that um
watched riddick yet oh hey sophia
it was great talking with you that was a
lot of fun um no i haven't and i i doubt
i'll re-watch
um the one that's actually called
riddick but i i i should re-watch
uh pitch black um because i own that one
um because yes i do still have physical
media is it weird to people if i come in
this close
and talk a little bit lower and turn
this into an asmr channel
good evening i'll try very hard not to
make any
clicking or wet sounds with my mouth
because that would just be
kind of disgusting and you don't want to
feel disgusted by me
you want to be entranced by my lovely
dulcet tones okay
that's enough of that um i've been
re-watching series eight of doctor who
wow 12 is hilarious plus his chemistry
with clara is awesome
they do have good chemistry she has
better chemistry with him than with
smith
uh i've always thought that if you have
seen clue which of the three endings is
the best one
the last one the real ending
oh my god i grew up on clue
so like i could recite
that whole flippin movie one plus two
plus two plus one
uh-uh that was only one shot that got
the chandelier so that's one plus two
plus one plus one
even if you were right that'd be one
plus one plus two plus one not one plus
two plus one plus one
people who haven't seen clue have no
idea what i just went on about they're
probably wondering did she just have a
stroke
uh karen gillum is mara jade matt smith
is grand emerald thrawn
just thoughts aren't going to happen
well i've heard that karen gillan's
margin is like a
rumor that circulated i don't think
there's any
meat on that bone at least not at
present
uh i think kenda is it uh at least is
enough of a departure from davis and
zera
uh is what it's usually like has more in
common with castrovalva
i do like castrovalva i think that was
actually a really strong start
let's see
oh god this wicked wolf i'm not gonna
i'm not
breaking out into song on here i will
you will get the stream demonetized
i've got english in wales on my mother's
side and scotland and ireland are my
fathers
you want to know the weird thing i've
got a sliver of egyptian
for the weirdest reason and like
not enough that i can claim like and
that's my heritage so i can
wear certain you know clothes from that
culture no i can't
i'm super white but i do have a little
bit of that in me
because a sailor got lost
like a ship got turned around and
he he ended up um in the wrong place and
just decided to stay there
and got mixed in the gene pool so
i'm a little bit egyptian go figure
choice thank you real life julie oh you
get another heart
i'm just stealing this from you jessie
she watches the playback i i want to see
her face i like i almost want to see
jesse blind react
to the uh to the archive of this and me
stealing this whole bit from her
uh the thin mints but not necessarily
the samoas
but seriously yeah i know i know coconut
is
coconut is a divisive ingredient in
almost anything um
i was gonna say almost like how
pineapple is divisive on pizza but
honestly i don't know that many people
who have a problem with
pineapple on pizza most people i know
are at least okay
with it i'm just saying i think it's a
minority of people who have just blown
it out of proportion trying to make it
seem like nobody on the planet likes
pineapple on their pizza
they're wrong
thanks so much for getting my name right
every time i'm still thrilled that i've
gotten it right
since the first time like that's that is
a stupidly high point of pride for me
ah it's it's i'm still getting used to
working around
this mic um probably heard on a couple
of videos where
where i've bumped it uh here or there
uh let's see
have you seen the link i commented i
might have missed it
um black cover so i'm not sure which one
you're referring to
do you think doctor strange will appear
in one division
no i wouldn't rule it out but if you
were gonna press me for it i would say
no
i love the way you chuckle oh thank you
uh don't want to hear clicky and wet
sounds but how would you feel
about an a nice chianti
i'm i am so sorry i apologize
to everybody's ears for that it's my
birthday today happy birthday ian
cheers 38 but i feel like i'm in my 20s
yeah
i am
i will be 39 next month
when am i supposed to start feeling like
an adult
cause i don't like
at all to the point that i'm like
starting to become concerned
clues in the small pantheon films i've
can quote the entirety of
the police will be here in half an hour
and there are two
dead bodies in the study
well there's still some confusion as to
whether there's anyone else in this
house i told you there isn't there isn't
any confusion
or there isn't anyone else either or
both just give me a clear answer
certainly what was the question is there
anyone else in the house
no
oh that's what i'm talking about when i
say i know that movie too dang well
at 60. oh well okay
uh on your it'll be okay video on tick
tock i pressed my forehead against the
phone screen oh
i i hope i hope that you liked that that
yeah i'm 42 i feel like i'm 15.
that tracks that totally tracks
you do feel like an adult you just had a
false preconception of what adulthood is
supposed to feel like
yeah philosophically i can buy that
that's what he says but does he know
well picked up john
thank you real life julie again you know
what by that point mwah
have that uh what's in your tardis-sized
ale mug tonight um this is warmed up
cider
cinnamon stick and all um
with additives
have you seen dreg i don't know what
drag is
uh question have you heard the
who they're a [ __ ] metal band and
they're awesome
have not heard of them i don't listen to
a lot of metal it's honestly not really
my thing
um my interest in metal kind of begins
and ends with blind guardian
and even them i don't listen to that
much anymore who would you
most like to play in a clue play can't
say all of them
wadsworth oh my god please
uh my great-grandmother came
here to america from ireland in the
early 1900s
nice my family was here when the country
was being founded
in other words this is all my fault
i am sorry
[Music]
husbands should be like kleenex soft
strong and disposable
you lure men to their deaths like a
spider with flies flies are where men
are most vulnerable right
are the additives legal yes
oh my god it didn't even occur to me
that people would think i was implying
illicit drugs it was
mead it was mold mead that i added
it's yes it's legal
oh one of liz's friends makes it like
she has a license
to make it she has a meadery in her
garage
the writer for human nature apparently
proposed the story
proposed a story for season eight where
12 or clara became a vampire
well that would have been paul cornell
wouldn't it
i could see him proposing that story
uh
i met him um galifrey won
last year
what should nerd try to rename his
channel
i'll never watch regardless so i don't
care
uh as far as i know i'm half german and
half french
that's a that's a loaded statement as
far as i know
see the thing is like i haven't had um
i haven't had my dna tested um oh
discord thank you carowind i will get to
that in
just a minute um thank you very much
um like i i haven't had my dna tested
but like i have
family members who are into genealogy
and have done a lot of work like
did it decades ago before like
ancestry.com
was even a thing before i even had the
internet in my house
so um
[Music]
it uh when i say like
when i talk about my lineage it's based
largely off of that i don't know what
the actual percentages are if i were to
get
um if i were to get a dna test i don't
know what percent of that [ __ ]
uh i would be all right so let uh give
me a second folks i gotta pop over the
discord which makes this
my obligatory plug to uh maybe consider
supporting me uh over on patreon because
the discord
is a patreon exclusive perk and also you
know
it uh having the support of people over
there is what allows me to have
cider and mold mead
and also pay my bills and feed my kid
alright so that's that
okay no way i can stay up this time
question to follow
question if you cosplayed as an existing
companion i.e
not one not your invention of one
and not a doctor who do you think you
would choose and why
ace cause ace is awesome
and also like has the coolest jacket and
i'd get to have the baseball bat
as um as a prop oh yeah
aces ace is an easy call for that
um second to that would be jamie because
i could wear the kilt
although i'm pretty sure jamie didn't
shave his legs
and i would i don't always but if i'm
gonna wear
a kilt if i'm gonna show the legs off
i'm gonna shave them
that's just what i'm gonna do would be
less painful for me to watch the movie
cats if i pretended
that this was set in the red dwarf
universe and this was the planet that
the feline sapiens conquered
that might be the only way it makes any
kind of sense
yeah actually that makes a heck of a lot
more sense than the film does as it
exists
uh and somebody within the uh discord
reply that no suffering will be
inevitable
oh yeah like it'll still be bad but it
might be um
amusing in a different way okay i am
back in the chat
uh i haven't seen one division because
i'm sort of burnt out on superhero stuff
fair although i would say that one
division
is while it has superhero characters
it's not
really a superhero genre show but it's
still dealing with that world and those
characters so if you
are burnt out on the characters
and not just the specifics of superhero
genres then yeah it might be better to
wait
hey donna thank you
have a heart wild additives
with girl scout cookies
[Laughter]
um that that's going to be my next merch
launch
is a is a line of edibles
no no
it's 220 here in germany to hell with
time zones
wow that is yeah that's a uh
that's a little late
uh oh you must be mr green
yes sit no not you sir
oh take them away chief
i'm gonna go home and sleep with my wife
[Music]
and i'll stop singing um did you watch
the uh perseverance landing how cool was
that
i did not i'm assuming that's
mars probe i'm gonna guess
yeah no i didn't um yeah like the thing
is the thing you need to realize
when i was growing up i got burnt out
because like i swear to god
every time there was a a
shuttle launch it would be advertise
it would be broadcast on tv and
we used to get huddled around to watch
it i don't know why they would do that
you think they learned their lesson
after the freaking challenger happened
which thankfully i didn't watch live
i was a little young for that but yeah
jeez
it was what is under doom
cock's mask a gaping void of personality
you're welcome uh since the pandemic
started a year ago
yep uh yep that was uh that was a
thought that was hitting me today that
was a depressing notion
um do you cook a lot more or do you just
do take out a lot
uh except for a few occasions i mainly
do cooking at home
it's actually about the same as it was
before because i can't afford to eat out
more than i already was
um so
like eating at home is what i do most of
the time anyways so
my eating habits haven't really changed
have you seen have you seen it yet
i'm not sure what the it is i don't know
if that's supposed to be capital
i uh i see it like the movie it or
i don't you you're referencing something
that i'm missing
uh have you seen dracula untold with
luke heavens
uh no no i missed that one
oddly for some reason i looked at the
trailer and thought
that won't go anywhere and it didn't so
uh my minor quibble for it's a sin was
that most
music choices for the end credits were
either songs that were overused or very
jarring plus the credits rush by too
quickly
um here's the thing
i actually support the use of those
songs only as end credit songs if any of
them had appeared in the body of the
show
like i might have groaned but for end
credits yeah
i will say though given how good most of
those songs were
uh it was annoying that the credits
ended like
one minute into the song and i'm like
but
okay call death uh cake please
have you seen dracula untold oh i read
that already um
[Laughter]
do you think red skull could return to
the mcu due to the fact
uh he's freed from his curse i doubt he
will in any significant way because
they were able to cover up the fact that
hugo weaving won't do the role again
um because he was shrouded he was in
darkness they got a sound alike and they
used cgi
but i think for a significant appearance
it's gonna be a bit more
obvious and that's not i mean the marvel
universe isn't above recasting they've
recast before
but i mean who wants to
who wants to take the place of hugo
weaving for more than just a scene
that's that's a tough act to follow but
i mean maybe they could but the other
reason i'm inclined to say they won't
is red skull is a captain america
villain like iconically so
and with steve having retired out
i don't think you're ever going to get
the same weight behind bringing back red
skull
because you know it's meant to be
the eternal struggle of you know the
the demonic nazi
versus america's ass and that's supposed
to be the conflict
so when you're missing half that
equation
is it worth bringing this back i don't
know
where's dr stewart doctor who sir for
you right now terminus this fifth doctor
it's not good
set during the outbreak of a virus oh
goody
i'm 23 years old am i the youngest
person here you might be
you might be because i'm old as hell
i'm not really but um you know
sometimes i i i look at the fact that i
am
a little over a year away at having to
say that i'm
40.
seeing as the song from episode four is
basically
owned by san junipero yeah but
like i like the song i like
i get it i i'm not disagreeing with the
criticism only saying it didn't really
bug me that much
um
what what if doom [ __ ] was a classic
doctor who villain
uh
he could be the um oh what the heck is
it the
the half hybrid thing from um
time lash whatever the heck it was that
they implies the loch ness monster
uh that was the best description of cap
versus the red skull
you are welcome
21 20 21. i'm 15.
who let these children into my stream
get off my lawn no it's fine
it's fine like the the channel here is
all ages
it's my tick tock you need to keep off
of if you're under 18.
but that's that's that's another
conversation
40 40s going to be 43.
in comics retirement and death doesn't
exist so cap
could come back any time well yeah in
the comics
it can but like they won't recast chris
evans
like they retired the character the
character in the movies is
done i guess i'm not the youngest it
would appear
not not today
i'm sorry but i just think of 40 is the
next great adventure maybe with
the doctor
[Laughter]
that means you're only three years away
from life the universe and everything
yes yes i will be the answer but i still
won't know the question
cat should have been an animated movie
cats shouldn't have been a movie
like that just on premise that was a
flawed idea
at all the borad
thank you john thank you very much that
was the time lash villain that i was
trying to think
get off my line she says right before
she remembers we give her money
fine you can be on the lawn but turn
down the music
darn kids
[Music]
hello kitty or pusheen i think pusheen's
cuter
personally squishy
nsync are the backstreet boys
there were legitimate fights
in my high school about that
a backstreet boys for the record
everybody
uh did someone already mention that
richie
is partly based on dursley mclinden who
played mike in remembrance of the daleks
i don't think anybody mentioned it in
chat i did know that
because after i finished it i did look
into a little bit of the
the writing and the conception uh behind
it
cats could have worked as an animated
feature i think
all right here's here's what i'll say it
would have been better than live action
because if they had done like not
humanoid cats but just cats
animated cats you know 2d hand-drawn
ideally
not cgi um
that would have made it visually
distinct enough
from the stage play to warrant at least
the existence of the thing
i would still argue that
too much of cats too much of katz's
appeal as a show
is the direct rapport with a live
audience
for it to have ever really been worth
doing
but it would have been um
more valid a choice artistically
can you hum for us i mean i can
i won't um my dad keeps asking
a question that being cis i don't know
how to answer
why do you identify as gender fluid why
don't you just identify as human i do
identify as human
but like
does does your dad just identify why
does your dad identify as a man
why doesn't he just identify as human
like you wouldn't ask that question
of anyone other than someone who doesn't
make sense to you
but think of the absurdity of that if
someone were to ask him
dude why you got to be all like i'm a
man
just be a human he looked at them like
they were
nuts and it's
not any better to ask that of someone
like me
but i am a human i do identify as a
human
but it's not all i am it is not the
it does not even begin to explain the
nuance of what i am because
everyone is a human
so that doesn't tell you anything about
me
knowing that i'm gender fluid or knowing
that someone is a man or a woman
or non-binary or trans is information
about them
that human human human doesn't tell you
[ __ ] you
might as well say why don't you just
identify as a carbon-based life-form
that's that's useless there's no
information
in that
i mean that that's like saying why do i
have to use your name why can't i just
call you
hey you because it's information
it is part of who you are it is an
aspect of your identity and if you
choose to share it that is valid
sorry i'm getting slightly worked up um
i don't know your dad i don't know if
he's asking that
facetiously as a joke in bad faith or
sincerely
but yeah
dad hey
think about what think about the context
of what you're asking
or what your what it is you're saying
because if you take it outside the
context you're using it
putting it in literally any other
context you would realize how absurd
that is
okay i'm saying that as politely as i
can
because i i understand that it's
confusing for people
but you know we're just trying to be
we're just trying to exist and to feel
seen and valid
so saying why don't you just identify as
human is also basically just saying why
can't you just go back in the closet you
queer
and that's me being slightly less polite
about it because
i won't go back in the [ __ ] closet
nobody should have to anyone who is
willing to be out invisible with who
they are
should ever be asked veiled or
deliberately well i
always failed it's always veiled at this
point because it is no longer
fashionable to say
well why can't you just pretend you're
not what you are
now it's why can't you not talk about it
it's the same
sentiment either way you want us back in
the closet
you don't want to look at us you don't
want to have to
think about us you don't want to have to
comprehend our existence
because in some way
us existing is uncomfortable to you
and the reason for that might vary it
could be any number of things
but most frequently why it's
uncomfortable to you
is that our existence challenges your
perception of the world
it's why people wanted gay people in the
closet because their understanding of
the world
their understanding of the relationship
between men and women their
understanding of biology or religion
or natural order or whatever it was was
challenged by the existence of
homosexual people
and the existence of genderfluid people
non-binary people and even
binary trans people is a challenge to
the perception of lots of people of what
gender is
and they would rather not see the thing
that makes them realize they don't know
everything
than to actually grapple with what the
existence of people like me
or anyone who isn't cisgender and
heterosexual actually means for their
outlook and their perspective on the
world
i almost have more respect for people
who flat out say
i just don't like queer people
because at least there's no
self-delusion there
because to the questions like why can't
you just
not talk about it or anything that
amounts to that
to that sentiment you're asking
us to give you permission to pretend we
don't exist
so that you can delude yourself and not
deal with your own thoughts and feelings
and no i'm not going to enable you to do
that sort out your [ __ ]
that turned into a thing okay
hope everyone's okay hope you're all
hope i didn't scare anyone off
last week tonight yay or nay i love last
week tonight
i enjoy that a lot speaking of doctor
who it's incredible that it's been going
on
uh since the 30s props to the character
i feel like you're messing with me there
okay what have i i've got a um
let's see identify as an alien visitor
to this planet
feels like that way sometimes doesn't it
oh since the 60s there it is okay so
there was a correction
done there i'm gay it's the fourth of
july and i want to keep it that way
darn right darn right have you heard of
that vegan teacher
yes yes i've heard of that vegan teacher
who
last i checked
has been banned off tick tock
took long enough given the nonsense she
was saying
but yes i'm regrettably familiar with
her
um oh thank you real life julie
thank you so much i don't want to go
back into the effing closet go you
oh yes i will go i will go anywhere
other than in the damn closet
[Laughter]
if you have a mic you should drop it no
this mic was expensive
i'm i'm not i am not dropping it
uh and somebody even pointed that out
not
not the kind of mic to be dropped safely
you mentioned you dislike how
no one is likeable in davidson's run
what uh works better
about it in androzani um
i think a lot of it and i haven't
rewatched in drazani in a while
so i'm working off memory i think part
of the difference there
is that um
[Music]
i think there's a lot clearer
drive for the doctor in regards to perry
where if i'm going to compare it to
something
like um like resurrection of the daleks
which i just watched recently
there you know turlow was never really
in danger he was just kind of there and
tegan just got knocked out
and was sidelined for the whole thing
whereas
and and i suppose this actually speaks
to some degree
of the merits of the damsel
in distress trope now obviously
that is a trope with a lot of baggage
some of it
very bad and you need to be careful with
how you deploy it but
one of the reasons that it can be used
well and it does still get utilized
is that it can give you a direct
um inherent hook in by giving you a
speci
rather than a nebulous danger
for a town or a kingdom
or a planet or what have you there's a
specific danger to a specific person and
if you're invested in that person
like this is generally the best way to
deploy the damsel in distress trope
not to have it be basically the trophy
the girl in the tower at the end of the
thing no if if you
damsel a character that there's some
investment in or that a character who
you
are invested in cares about enough then
that can hook you in and bring some
personal stakes where otherwise they
would be lacking
into my memory that's part of what
worked about
caves of androzani um but again
i have not rewatched that one in a while
where did you ate your pride ring
this one uh was actually sent to me um
because
my old one cracked it's actually sitting
uh
over there on my desk um
so and and i had said i'd never seen it
anywhere else so i didn't think i could
replace it somebody found a replacement
and sent it to me
where i got the original one was a
vintage store
um which i think is the reason i have
not been able to find
this elsewhere again somebody did find
it and sent me an intact replacement so
now i've got two
one cracked one intact ooh
rhymes i should probably wrap up soon um
actually
it looks like i'm late to the party hey
nothing hey randomness
yeah i mean i'd start a little later
than usual
but uh
what are your thoughts on the little
prince um
oh okay
my thoughts on the movie the little
prince
first off i'll try and keep this brief
only because if you
really care about my thoughts about that
i have a video up
i have a review on this channel
of that movie i hated
it
the 30 minutes or so
that is an actual adaptation of
the story of the little prince is
great and if i could remove that and
watch that as a short
film i would because it's gorgeous it's
visually stunning
it's perfectly captured it is beautiful
but the other 70 of the movie that wraps
around that the framing device
is all about how awesome the story of
the little prince is
it is this self-congratulatory
masturbatory mess
it lost me the longer it went on and by
the time it was done
i hated it
i really ri that movie and it infuriates
me because it's got like a 92 percent on
rotten tomatoes or something
and it is so it is one of the most
self-congratu self-congratulatory
pretentious
films i have ever seen
i hate it so much and i say that as
someone who
likes the original work or at least the
bits of it that i know because i don't
know the whole thing front to back
and the parts where they're actually
adapting it are beautiful
but everything else that is tossed in is
garbage
absolute self-important unreflective
horrible steaming garbage
that movie's terrible
and it's more terrible for ruining the
parts of it that are
great
uh you set me off a little bit on that
uh
i'm so glad i saved androzani for last
for the davison era to watch i never
watched classic in order
oh well let's see i've got i've got a
few more to catch up on it looks like
i've got a super chat to grab then i'm
probably going to wrap up
a way of thinking i believe in with all
my heart
is it can always be worse so take what
you can get specifically when it comes
to media i mean yeah
i uh i have a kind of a reflective
uh wince at the phrase it could always
be worse
um i i i don't mean to like um
knock your your philosophy um
[Music]
because obviously you you've you've got
more to it than just that sentiment but
that sentiment
in isolation of it could always be worse
i i hate when people say that trying to
be comforting
or you're like yeah things aren't great
they're like well it could be worse
it could always be worse that doesn't
mean that it's not terrible right now
why do you think that is comforting
not directed at you like just as a
general thing like i said i kind of
wince
um just a boring straight person but i
support my lgbtqia brothers and sisters
aaron there is nothing wrong with being
straight
being lgbtqia lgbtq plus
whatever it doesn't make
anyone who is any of those things
more special or unique than you are
the only reason that we are singled out
is because
frustratingly significant swaths of
society
don't accept us if we had proper
equality
we wouldn't even have to bring attention
to our sexualities or our gender
identities we could just
be the fact that we
have to be out and or defensive
and or secretive about ourselves is not
because of any inherent specialness that
we have that you don't
it's because the world hasn't always
made space for us so we have to make
space for ourselves but that's
circumstance
don't shortchange yourself by saying
you're just a boring straight person
wonderful person
being straight doesn't diminish that
and my being really freaking queer
doesn't make me any more special
uh do you have letterboxed i do uh
actually
i do have letterboxed um
i'm not sure i want to heavily advertise
what my username on there is
um because
like there's a reason i i don't use
ratings in my reviews i don't like
people sorting my um
my views on films by a number assigned
to them and
like that's not saying i'm above rating
films but like i hate the idea that
somebody could
say oh you thought this movie was better
than this one because you gave this
a four stars and this is a three and
like no just i would rather you
listen to my opinions i kind of share
yahtzee kroshaw's views on
the reductive nature of scores but the
very
nature of letterbox is that i'm putting
a score on something
which i'm happy to do but i don't really
want that overly tied to me
uh if that makes sense
uh when people ask me to go back in the
closet i say
gladly i've got some fierce clothes in
there
good answer john m chu is directing the
wicked movie what are your thoughts i
don't know his other work and this is
like the fourth person who's supposedly
gonna direct a wicked movie so
until they actually cast the thing and
it goes into production
i have absolutely zero opinion
oh thank you selena that's a heart for
you
thank you very much just want to send
love
uh to you for making my tuesday so much
better when you go live oh
thank you thank you very much
i i i actually want to thank you
you folks because even though i get
um i do kind of get worked up
um sometimes even on the stream
uh like it it these do help
because like it hasn't been the best day
but it's nice to unwind
with you folks
uh what is your favorite ghibli film if
you have one
my neighbor totoro i've seen the 1974
musical film of the little prince with
gene wilder is the fox that's pretty
good ooh
i didn't know about that one movies that
wild hates but everyone else seems to
love
the shining ferris bueller dumb and
dumber greece the little prince oh yeah
i guess we're up to five
now there's probably more uh i do find
that amusing would people like have
managed to keep track of stuff that i've
just said
and i don't really keep track of um
there was a comment
on um i think the link to one of the
podcast episodes where someone had
catalogued a number of stuff so wait
this this this and now
this about you i'm like well yeah
at least i got to see a rant yes yes you
did
idea parody song manor muppet but about
gender fluidity
oh maybe i do like that song
am i a man
can't keep singing um thank you very
much alex
thank you have a heart do you think the
most recent episode of one division
uh almost confirms mephisto
[Music]
no i mean
okay so here's the uh this is a
potential
spoiler i'll try and be vague about this
but um
so the character that gets introduced in
the most recent episode
in the comics is absolutely connected to
mephisto
that does not necessarily mean it's
going to be the case in the film they
rework and
reshot i mean just just just look at the
character
they look very very different there's
obviously a huge age difference between
how the character normally appears
in the comics and how they are appearing
on this show
so they're already taking massive
liberties and i
and they've done this across the board i
mean in the mcu
vision is was invented by tony stark in
the
comics it's hank pym you know the things
change all the time
so just because they introduced the
character with ties to mephisto does not
necessarily mean that we are going to
get mephisto
that said is possible but given that
they now have to explain this character
having to then bring in mephisto on top
of that with only a couple of episodes
left to go
i think that's trying to do too much of
one to go
i think they just need to deal with the
character that was introduced
and then if they feel the need to
introduce mephisto at a later date
and tie this character to him
you know they're around and they can do
that but
i i don't think it uh i don't think that
their mere existence confirms mephisto
sorry i have
ms wicked wolf
are are you are you going back through
my reviews
and selectively finding the ones that
you know
you know i hate
and then asking me about them here
because at this point little prince i
was prepared to throw off as a
as a coincidence this one thi
this coming right after that this feels
targeted
this is strategic on your part
i see you i see you
and as for me and the earl and the dying
girl that is not a movie
not really a movie is about characters
and occasionally characters have quirks
meaning on the dying girl does not have
characters who have quirks
it has quirks walking around pretending
to be characters
and it sucks
it sucks so much it was the worst movie
i saw from that year
it is abysmal i actually got mad at the
person who recommended it to me
i asked what have i ever done to make
you think that i would ever
enjoy that
hey okay are you excited for one
division to lead into doctor strange the
multiverse of madness i mean
i'll be curious to see how it does you
say that it's not like the
movie's coming out right away so we'll
see how much they actually end up
factoring in
i'm still expecting it to be less than
everyone else thinks it's going to be
uh what was the first movie you remember
being truly disappointed by
ghostbusters 2 not that i'm bitter
or anything uh edgar wright is
uh is to direct a remake of the running
man i saw that i'll be curious to see
you're more than a queen you're a
goddess
um john m chu directed crazy rich asians
and the film adaptation of into the
height
of in the heights which i haven't seen
and crazy rich asians was
fine who is your doctor my doctor right
now
is capaldi it's changed before
um i do need to wrap up soon i said that
i said that like 20 minutes ago
um maybe a little bit in bad taste now
but i kind of wish the true villain of
one division was
emma caulfield's character just to see
her hold a bunny
[Laughter]
that would have been deliciously meta
i i like that one randomness i like that
one a lot
and thank you ben instead of a heart i'd
like a nod i'm british oh okay i i don't
want to
offend your british sensibilities by
showing too much direct affection so
well done well done
there i think i think we'll get away
with it there
there's a documentary called room 237
uh about theories people claim to have
seen
in the shining oh god a lot of them make
me go
nurse they're out of bed again oh god
that movie
uh best katherine han marvel villain
doc hawker i get that doc hawk not even
close i'm telling jesse you stole her
hearts
oh bring it on
um actually on that note the character
that is normally portrayed as
older is it just me or does it seem like
she looks a little older through the
episodes i
think that's you i think that's just
going from black and white
uh which is more forgiving to color and
higher resolution
yeah i think you're just seeing the the
age more
mephisto might be a thanos situation
with a credit scene background setup one
division
i really doubt it but then again i am
downplaying um how much i think
you're beautiful when you're ranting oh
thank you
um i i am
people are really jumping on this idea
that
the disney plush shows are gonna really
be truly heavily integrated and integral
to the
marvel films going forward like they're
not
and i know kevin feige said they would
be and i'm sure they will be
more so than agents of shield or the
netflix things were
but at the end of the day they're not
going to be essential they never will be
and i believe that very firmly so i
like people like oh they're going to set
up this for the
films like it's possible that certain
things might be introduced but they're
not really going to be set up for the
film they're still going to be
brought into the film as if people don't
know who they already are
because fewer people watch the shows and
kevin feige knows that
uh oh that knot was at almost 90 degrees
it's getting hot in here oh
oh did i did i uh did i breach etiquette
should i should i have kept my ankles
together do i need to cross across my
legs
because um
because actually because of how close
the uh i've got the computer set up oops
um my my legs are
my legs are splayed open straddling the
stool
that i have my computer mounted on
oh dear
i think on that note we're going to
finally wrap it up
so thank you everybody for tuning in
oh god i can hear the grandfather clock
uh chiming out in the hallway so yes
i'm done that's definitely a clue um
thank you very much for tuning in um
i hope that everybody uh takes care
of yourselves um so
next month
is my birthday month
um and
if if you are able and are feeling
generous
there are in the descriptions of my
videos
links to my amazon wishlist and in more
recent ones i've added my etsy wish list
as well that having been
said my preference
would be um supporting me on patreon
but if you either already do that
or are uncomfortable with that as a
platform or for whatever reason you
don't want to you still want to get me
something those are there and available
as is my p.o box address if you want to
go that way
but uh we'll wrap it up there
thank you my legs are splayed open
somebody clipped that oh
god uh thank you all for tuning in
i hope that you have a wonderful rest of
the week
and please remember that you are
beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council i just run the
meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
my cavity